you say that once streaming hit it
changed everything streaming changed
everything because it allowed people to
make more choices it also allowed more
production it also broadened the idea of
the structure of Television because
way back in the earlier 2000s and before
that everything was in a four act
structure on television because it had
to allow for advertising every 13
minutes or so so you would divide your
60 minutes into roughly four acts
roughly four 15-minute segments they
weren't really exactly 15 minutes but
something like that it so that there
could be a commercial break at the end
of each one
and then there was a teaser
generally this traditional traditional
structure which I'll tell you is a
teaser
uh well let me start that again the
traditional structure was the uh Show's
title with even a theme song
then sometimes there was
a small commercial even right away
and then there's the teaser
anywhere from 30 seconds to five minutes
which uh literally teases the action or
sometimes in a procedural would give you
the crime or the case to be solved
then they'd be a commercial then you'd
go into act one which would go to
roughly
18 20 minutes 18 20 Pages then they'd be
a commercial act two would go to roughly
30-ish pages
this is traditional at break
uh act three which is the
worst case the climactic
encounter would go to roughly page 45
ish
and then at four would go to the end and
would be slightly shorter would probably
be 57 58 or 55 minutes and then there'd
be another act break uh and another uh
commercial
then it got longer and in uh 2006 uh ABC
decided that they wanted to go to Six
acts in order to stick stick in more
commercials
uh and so you ended up with a very long
act one
so the people wouldn't lose you and then
they break X6 into uh at four into
four and five and then there would be a
tag after the final Act which sometimes
led into the next week
um
and they would get more commercials in
and this just got worse and worse and
worse and worse uh where there were uh
some shows on traditional networks that
had almost more commercial material than
dramatic material and people got fed up
uh
one of the things about streaming is
that there were no commercials
the minute there were no commercials you
no longer had not only did you no longer
have that structure but you had actually
more air time
you had more flexibility of telling
stories now HBO always had no
commercials and the same was true of
Showtime
now you can get AMC with or without
commercials but I watched Better Call
Saul uh the other day as it's as it ran
on television as opposed to seeing it
streaming and I was appalled that this
wonderful storytelling kept being
interrupted by trying to sell me
something
and I the same thing's true of Hulu
where you could buy it with or without
commercials you just pay more if you
don't have the commercials I can't
imagine watching handmaid's tale uh you
know Disturbed every several minutes by
telling me something and I just don't I
just won't watch anything that way if I
can avoid it so that's part of the big
change it changed structurally but it
also changed the kind of material and it
changed the way people watched and the
and the number of choices people could
make
and I'm sure that encourages binge
viewing if there's no commercials
because you're so set in the story well
you can also continue because you know
and they know they they the purveyors of
these absolutely know that I think
Amazon does this that after you finish
an episode there's a little ticker thing
that says next episode starts in five
four three two one like no I'm not I
don't want to watch I sat here long
enough uh
but it's very easy to be glued for a
very long time and by the way this
disabuses the notion that young
audiences have shut such short times
such short attention spans that they
will only watch something that's three
minutes or 10 minutes long it was
discovered because it was tried on
YouTube
what would happen if we gave people the
option of watching 10-minute acts that
is 10-minute segments or and have 12 of
them to make a 120 minute movie
or
to let them look at old 10 one after
another after another after another
everybody watched all 10. uh so it's
just not true uh it has to do with
interest and attention it doesn't have
to do with something's wrong with the
brain of of young people who can't pay
attention for more than a few minutes if
they're interested enough they're there
sure and I mean if you have your morning
coffee I'm speaking more for myself I'm
going to be more add and switch around
than if it's later in the day and I'm
tired and now I don't have anything more
on my plate my attention is going to be
there so yeah well one of the things
about streaming is you can watch it at
any time I mean if if you're a morning
viewer you could see something that
would normally have been an evening show
at any time in the day
years ago when West Wing and er were on
and they always started at 10 pm
I knew I was going to be watching from
10 to 11 at night
I would rather not watch from 10 to 11
at night and I would rather see those
same shows at nine or any other time and
now I can
one last thing you'd set the tag forgive
me what is the tag oh a a uh in terms of
structure after you get to your final
Act
in some shows uh not all of them there's
a form where there's an act break or a
break of some sort and then there's more
dramatic material
and that extra dramatic material is
usually quite short it might be one
scene or two scenes maybe three scenes
but not really much longer and either it
does something as a commentary on what
that episode was about and twists it or
it just simply starts introducing what's
going to be on the next episode
every show is different you don't find
this sort of thing very much on on
streaming and so this we're really when
we talk about act breaks and the four or
five or six Acts or the number of Acts
plus the teaser and a tag we're really
we're really dealing with traditional
Legacy television
can you tell us about the four act Grid
in my book here there is an extensive
conversation about maybe I could find a
page here somewhere yeah here's a
picture of it and I it says using the
grid and I find and here is the non-grid
uh analyzing structure from a different
point of view
all right there's some other things that
you can find it in the book
um
I found that even after the traditional
Forex structure was abandoned by
Networks that as I talk to people who
are writing for Netflix or HBO or any
other form at all Amazon uh when I talk
to seasoned writers they were all still
using it and just dropping out the ACT
break
and the reason they were using it is
that it works it works as a storytelling
mechanism even if it does not need to be
something that accommodates advertising
and that was very interesting that given
the option to not use it plenty of
people figured out gee I need a form
anyway and you don't just start on page
one and go to page 60 or whatever you
know in a row without having any idea uh
where the where the changes are where
the emphasis are where the energy goes
this way or that way
what about Cliffhangers and it was
discovered by a number of of seasoned
writers that you know what I can go back
to the tools that I always used without
ever having calling it a break or having
an ad and what it has to do with the
rhythm of experience
that there is a something by I think
there may be something biological in the
roughly 15-minute span if you go to a
movie uh movie in a theater of which
there aren't very many anymore but if
you were to go in a movie
in a successful movie in a theater and
You observe you'd note you might notice
that roughly every 13 or to 15 minutes a
little around the audience squirms
and I've observed this several times and
I think it is actually biological I
think people are looking for a change of
pace they're looking for a cliffhanger
they're looking for
something that turns the action in
another Direction in what uh some people
have called the plot point though you
don't need to use that terminology and
uh I think there is something to rid the
rhythm of writing uh
in fact if you look at the traditional
three-act structure the the old Sid
feels three extractor which wasn't
invented by Sid Fields it predates him
by a long time but anyway
um
that structure said that act 1 act 1 was
one quarter of the time at two is two
quarters of the time half
and act three
is one quarter of the time and that's
how the three acts work they're not
three even acts the second act is double
but if you draw a median line down the
middle of that second act
which is often where the uh
mid Story character comes in and or
there's a big change you're back to
you've got four acts and so you're still
back to the same thing now it plays out
differently in a hundred minutes than it
would in 60 minutes but not that
differently
um
and so people experiment with what
Netflix will tell you and what HBO will
tell you uh is don't talk to me about
act breaks uh
write what the story needs
write it whatever length the story needs
to be and we'll deal with it
and I think that's wonderful as a very
generous way of approaching writers the
writer still has to go home and
structure the story
so what the story needs to be still
needs turns still needs anticipation
still needs what used to be called plot
points still needs a motor
that drives to certain kinds of flips
and and still needs some sort of
resolution so you find yourself back
with some of the most traditional uh
lessons in how to write as you write for
even the most advanced television
so for the outlining process if we were
to tell someone don't worry about plot
structure that could throw it off it
sounds like this is very necessary no I
I make my students write very very
structured outlines
they can
um I never say don't don't worry about
plot structure I ask them what is your
story and where are the turns and twists
and when do they occur and they'd better
know that before they start washing
around in a script that's an unknown
length going in unknown directions so no
that doesn't happen I I believe in a in
what I was taught which was that you get
a locked out line that you get a really
good outline and if you are outlined
tells the story well as driven by the
characters and has enough Cliffhangers
and twists and surprises and
anticipation your script will be easy to
write if you're if you're sweating your
script it's because there was something
wrong with the outline
that'll get a lot of comments because
there's two you know of course you know
there's people very resistant to it
no nobody likes to write outlines
outlines are uh
you know I with my students I tell them
when the outlines are done you're out of
outline jail because they're no fun they
don't give you a chance to show off your
ability as dialogue or description
they're not beautiful they're
engineering and creative people might
want to resist oh no you're going to you
know make it too rigid actually it's
freeing it's freeing if you know where
you're going you can go there very well
if you're lost you have a hard time
making anything work out